bonjour voici vos prévisions météo du 6
décembre 2005 quand on a reçu énormément
d'autres durant les dernières semaines
avec des orages qui ont été de passage
dans le sud du québec et le sud de
l'ontario et la bassée et changement du
tout au tout on a des conditions en
soleil évidemment mais surtout cette
douceur estivale qui persistent
d'ailleurs qui persiste en automne et ça
c'est une tendance qu'on remarque déjà
depuis quelques années faut savoir une
chose ses cuisses c'est vraiment
particulier c'est que les températures
qu'on connaît en ce moment sont des
températures qu'on a connue en fait en
octobre au début des années 2000 et
d'ailleurs vous allez le constater
parce que je vais vous montrer ce que ça
va donner une cours des prochaines
heures alors qu'évêques 13° montréal on
parle d'une quinzaine à surveiller c'est
surtout toronto 19 degrés ce secteur un
record qu'on pourrait battre aujourd'hui
un record qui date de 2000 31 où le
thermomètre avait atteint 1,7 degré il
faut comprendre une chose c'est que
d'ici la fin du siècle les températures
vont augmenter d'au moins trois degrés
supplémentaires
si les gaz à effet de serre continuent
d'augmenter je vous rappelle que dans
trois semaines qu'est ce qu'on a et bien
si noël je sais que plusieurs d'entre
vous souhaitent un noël blanc mais je
peux vous confirmer qu'à ce rythme là
dans le sud du québec où le sud de
l'ontario
encore une fois cette année on risque
d'avoir un noël vert on va se déplacer
dans les maritimes énormément d'action
ouragans kiel de catégorie 2 qui va
frapper la nouvelle écosse ainsi les 24
prochaines heures et légendes halifax
ont particulièrement créatif al'approche
de cette 11e tempête 11e ouragans
pourquoi parce que leur péninsule
ressemble beaucoup à celle de la floride
et les gens d'halifax
on trouve en tête maria un intense
ouragan qui a détruit une partie miami à
204,1 hees a causé la mort de plus de
3000 personnes et d'ailleurs faudrait
penser à repousser la date de la fin la
saison des ouragans
parce que les tempêtes tropicales se
produisent beaucoup plus tard dans la
saison donc en automne avancées elles
sont plus nombreuses qu'avant et remonte
pas mal plus souvent aussi la cote
en s'approchant des maritimes on va se
rendre maintenant du côté du passif et
qu'on attend de la pluie et du temps
frais il y aura des vins aussi qu'ils
vont sévir donc ce sera une mer très
agitée et ça évidemment ça n'aidera en
rien la région de vancouver qui a
vraiment des problèmes aux inondations
qui à peine à les régler parce que ça
touche d'ailleurs plusieurs secteurs
évidemment nous construit une trentaine
d'années des idées qu'elles étaient
efficaces à l'époque mais
on se rend bien compte que là pour
limiter les dégâts en ce moment c'est
beaucoup plus difficile que ce l'était à
l'époque parce que elles ont atteint
leur capacité maximale étant donné que
le niveau de la mer augmenté de 40 cm
depuis le début des années 2 alors
évidemment faudrait réfléchir à une
nouvelle solution
alors voilà je viens de vous présenter
un bulletin météo fictif basée sur des
études scientifiques sérieuses ce que je
viens d'écrire pourrait se rapprocher de
la réalité si évidemment vous feriez
pour réduire nos émissions de gaz à
effet de serre ce n'est pas une fatalité
parce que si on s'y met tous ensemble ce
scénario là pour évidemment demeurer du
domaine de la fiction